good morning john so i got some good
news i got some bad news about syria
that's a lie i only have bad news it is
only bad news it is a terrible situation
but there is no solving problems that
you don't understand so here it is in
the next five or six minutes we're gonna
understand syria
at least more than we did before all
right let's start at the foundation of
syria a bunch of western powers are
introducing the idea of nation states to
the rest of the world they draw a shape
on a piece of paper and say
this shape shall be syria inside that
shape are lots of different sorts of
people who have various degrees of
historical and social ties there are
christians and druze and sunni muslims
and alawites and of course pluralism
does not
necessarily breed violence but we let's
just
wait and see fast forward to the cold
war the first world of the usa and the
second world of the ussr
are nabbing up alliances with the third
world of
everyone else russia nabbed syria
through a combination of diplomacy and
giving guns they helped the ostensibly
socialist bath party
take control in syria the bath party was
run by alawites the leader was a guy
whose last name was
assad the father of the current assad
and even though the cold war is now over
though apparently no one has told the
united states defense budget russia
continues to be closely allied with
syria and relies on syria
for its sweet warm water ports which
russia lacks because it is russia in the
year since the bath party took over in
1970 syria has become kind of a
segregated place the scholarships go to
alawi children government contracts go
to alawi businesses there are literally
lanes of traffic that only alawite
people are allowed to drive in the
majority of syria are sunni muslim the
official sunni muslim stance on alawites
is that they have rejected the teachings
of islam
that combined with the fact that they've
been repressed for like 40 years creates
some sectarian tension that during the
arab spring
broke open this is a struggle between a
powerful minority and a disenfranchised
majority peaceful pro-democracy protests
were
swiftly punished by the assad regime
first by putting people in jail then
they kept protesting then they started
to kill them then they protested more
violently
then they started to torture their
children and killed their families
it's bad then a big hunk of the army
defected and became the free syrian army
continues however to get more confusing
while the original protest was a
pro-democracy protest and there are
still
many rebels fighting for a democratic
future there are now tons of different
rebel groups that all want different
things and some of them like each other
and some of them don't
some of them love al qaeda and some of
them love democracy this isn't star wars
there's no rebel alliance it's messy and
it's muddy and to make things worse
if we are talking about star wars here
assad has basically killed
luke skywalker and han and leia and
blown up
alderaan and admiral akbar's gone too
assad's forces have killed so many
non-alawite civilian and military
leaders that it's completely unclear
who the heck would take over if he left
now for years all this was happening
outside of the international spotlight
but then
chemical weapons president obama had
previously stated that there is a red
line and that if syria uses chemical
weapons
something and it looks as if assad's
forces did use chemical weapons sarin
gas was definitely used and it was
definitely used on the enemies of
assad's regime now claims to the
contrary to me
feel very much like 1960s america where
white people actually believed that
african-american radicals bombed an
african-american church in order to make
the kkk look bad russia
has veto power in the u.n security
council and they have never allowed the
u.n to take action against assad because
russia
loves assad and is the only eye they
have in the middle east and those warm
water pools
obama wants to enforce his red line even
without the u in support and the
american people
are like oh god no not again no
presidents like
well once upon a time it was congress's
job to decide whether or not we attacked
other countries so let's let them decide
which is funny because as we all know
if congress were on fire congress could
not pass the poor water on congress act
just like russia needs assad assad
needs russia and so assad is willing to
do a lot of what russia tells him to do
which leads us
to john kerry making the weirdest
possible accidental act of diplomacy of
all time when he was like yeah i mean
assad could prevent us from attacking
him he could swage us
by giving us all of his chemical weapons
it's not going to happen but he could do
it and raja was like oh hey hi oh
we can do that this is nice for russia
because now they get to put on the
well-mannered diplomatic hero hat which
they don't get to wear very much lately
due to all of their corruption
and dismantling of democracy and freedom
plus let's not forget that russia
blocking any possible action by the u.n
is why we are in this mess in the first
place now it's possible that russia is
just enabling
assad's stalling and if it happens it
will be extremely complicated to collect
a bunch of chemical weapons out of a
country that
is in the middle of a civil war but it
would be an excellent outcome to be able
to enforce the international norm
against chemical weapons
not have to blow anything up or ask
congress to do anything what it comes
down to is that anyone who says that
they know what we should do in this
situation is either
being disingenuous or they don't know
what they're talking about maybe
attacking assad and empowering the
rebels will save millions of lives maybe
it will cost millions of lives maybe the
power vacuum left by assad would be
filled with islamists who would be
sympathetic to al qaeda problem with the
future is that it is unknowable
and so we don't really know what we
should do but there is something that
we can do maybe not for the overall
geopolitics of the situation but for
individual people the syrian civil war
has displaced over 2
million people and if you would like to
join me in donating to the u.n refugee
agency
that money will go to helping those
people rebuild their lives john
i'll see you on tuesday